[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur public sénat
alexandre benalla à utiliser 20 fois ses
passeports depuis son licenciement
l'ancien chargé de mission aurait même
falsifié des documents pour obtenir un
passeport de service
il se serait ainsi rendu au tchad mais
aussi en israël au maroc et aux bahamas
des informations explosives révélée
aujourd'hui par la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale sur cette affaire benalla
elle a repris ses travaux cet après midi
patrick strzoda directeur de cabinet des
manuels macron a été le premier à être
entendu par les sénateurs
retour sur les temps forts de son
audition tout de suite mes chers
collègues de nouvelles informations sont
parus à la fin de l'année dernière
entraînant des mises au point de la
présidence de la république est une
action judiciaire du ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur benalla n'a
utilisé un passeport diplomatique pour
des déplacements alors qu'il avait été
mis fin à ses fonctions à la présidence
de la république il a été reçu en
audience avec des hommes d'affaires par
deux hautes personnalités notamment du
chef d'état et en particulier le
président tchadien
quelques jours avant la visite du
président français au tchad de multiples
informations font état d'une activité
professionnelle débordante dans la
nature restent obscures il a été avancé
puis en partie démenties que des
contacts réguliers avaient été maintenus
entre le chef de l'état et son ancien
collaborateur
ce matin encore nous apprenons que des
titres officiels
il ya un téléphone permettant des
communications cryptées aurait été
restitués il ya quelques jours seulement
par monsieur benalla sent d'ailleurs
avoir été réclamé par la présidence de
la république
d'autres informations qui ont donné lieu
à une réaction exprimant la
préoccupation de la présidence de la
république font état d'un contrat entre
monsieur kraz
et un oligarque russe à une date où
monsieur kraz était encore chargé
d'encadrer les réservistes de la
gendarmerie participant à la sécurité du
palais de l'elysée je vous informe que
monsieur kraz a démenti ces informations
dans un courrier qui nous a adressé hier
nous avons nous avions déjà observé la
difficulté rencontrée à partir du 2 mai
dernier par l'elysée pour sanctionner
monsieur benalla de manière effective et
au niveau qui convenait et aussi les
difficultés rencontrées pour que la
justice soit saisie des faits du 1er mai
nous ne pouvions laisser sans réponse
les questions soulevées pour ces
nouvelles informations
je vais maintenant proposer à nos
rapporteur de vous poser quelques
questions par qui va commencer madame
jourdain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président je suis d'accord je vais
commencer par une question laquelle je
crois que vous pourrez répondre à des
feux dans quatre sur ce point le
président ballard à pied tout à l'heure
la presse s'est fait écho cette semaine
de ce que beaucoup ont analysé comme un
manque de diligence de la part de la
présidence de la république pour obtenir
la restitution par monsieur benalla de
plusieurs facilités depuis des objets
dont ils disposaient dans le cadre de
ses fonctions
parmi les éléments qui ont été citées
figurent tout d'abord un téléphone
théorème qui est un téléphone ultra
sécurisé dont monsieur benalla aurais-tu
lusage dans le cadre de ses missions à
l'elysée et qu'il aurait depuis son
licenciement conserver pourriez vous
nous indiquer à quelle fin monsieur
bénard à disposer d'un tel outil si tel
est le cas très bien madame à porter
j'ai effectivement hier soir en lisant
un hebdomadaire pris connaissance d'un
certain nombre de choses que je dois
aujourd'hui remettre dans leur contexte
et c'est bien volontiers que je vous
donnerai tous les éléments en à
disposition en cet instant
le téléphone en question s'appelle un
théorème
il est développé par la société thalès
donc tout le monde aura compris l'humour
le théorème de thalès
de quoi s'agit-il c'est un combiné
téléphonique qui permet d'échanger des
conversations chiffres et donc sécurisé
cela nécessite que les deux
correspondants et le même type de
matériel ce système théorème est très
répandue dans l'appareil d'état
puisqu'il existe 4600 terminaux qui sont
déployées auprès d'eux les autorités de
l'état mais également de ce qu'on
appelle les olives et les opérateurs
d'importance vitale
ce sont par exemple des entreprises
stratégiques pour la nation
contrairement à ce qu'affirme
l'hebdomadaire auquel je faisais
référence
ce matériel n'est pas classée secret
défense ne s'agit pas d'un matériel
relevant de la législation secret
défense
alors qu'en est il du déploiement de
théorèmes dans les services de l'elysée
il existe dans les services de la
présidence d'un public 30 combiné
théorème qui sont utilisés par plusieurs
services
d'abord le service de l'état major
particulier du chef d'état service qui
est dirigée par un amiral ensuite les
aides de camp qui officie dans la
proximité du président de la république
sont également équipés de ce dispositif
tout comme les membres de la cellule
diplomatique qui sont au nombre de
17 et qui ont tous rangs de diplomate et
un poste un poste est attribué à la
chefferie
c'est à dire l'équipe de trois cadres à
qui sous mon autorité gère l'agenda du
président un public et organise ses
déplacements ce poste qui a été donc été
attribué à la chefferie a été affecté à
monsieur ben ali au moment de son de son
licenciement
monsieur benalla aurait dû rendre ce
combiné tout salarié qui quitte une
entreprise définitivement rend toutes
les affaires qui appartiennent à
l'employeur c'est une obligation
et en l'occurrence n'a pas été respecté
dans le courant de l'été
donc monsieur benalla a quitté l'elysée
le 1er août dans le courant de l'été le
bureau de monsieur benalla a fait
l'objet d'une perquisition
c'était le 26 juillet 2018 au cours de
laquelle les enquêteurs ont saisi un
certain nombre d'objets sans nous dire
lesquels sont pas obligés de nous dire
quels sont les objets qu'ils ont pris
d'autres objets qui était dans le bureau
de monsieur benalla ont été rendus aux
différents services de l'elysée les
moyens informatiques au service
informatique il y avait également des
objets personnels qui ont été rangés
dans un carton après la réalisation d'un
inventaire carton qui est toujours à
l'elysée que monsieur le dallas n'a pas
récupéré et le 4 octobre le 4 octobre au
cours d'un inventaire périodiques
effectué par le service qui est
gestionnaire des dispositifs théorème il
a été constaté que le combiné qui était
affecté à monsieur benalla étaient
manquants n'était plus à l'elysée
et entre temps on avait pu s'assurer que
les enquêteurs ne l'avait pas pris donc
le 4 octobre le service gestionnaire a
immédiatement rendu le matériel
inutilisable dernière qu'on ne pouvait
plus utiliser pour converser en toute
sécurité avec un certain nombre
d'autorités et ce responsable du service
a également immédiatement exploité les
journaux de connexion du poste qui avait
été attribué à monsieur benalla pouvoir
s'ils avaient été utilisés et cet
appareil n'avait plus été utilisé depuis
le 1er juillet donc même si l'appareil
n'a été neutralisé que le 4 octobre
nous pouvons affirmer que il n'a pas été
utilisé à compter du 1er juillet 2018
donc n'y a plus aucune conversation
chiffré entre monsieur benalla et
quelques autorités que ce soit 11
janvier donc il ya quelques jours le
conseil de monsieur benalla m'a informé
que le post théorème avaient été
retrouvés dans les affaires de monsieur
benalla là où il vit aujourd'hui il est
à l'étranger et donc le conseil se
propose de le restituer rapidement à
l'elysée quand j'ai appris ça j'ai
déclenché une enquête interne
c'est-à-dire hier soir pour savoir
pourquoi les chefs de service qui ont en
charge la gestion des théorèmes à
l'elysée n'ont pas engagé de démarche
dans le courant de l'été
pour contacter monsieur benalla afin de
lui demander de restituer ce matériel l'
enquête est en cours
j'en aurais très vite les résultats et
j'en tirerai toutes les conséquences
entre la date du licenciement de
monsieur b nana et le 4 octobre
aucune diligence n'a été accompli pour
retrouver ce téléphone théorème pouvez
vous me dire dans quelles conditions
tous les objets
avait été confiée à monsieur benalla
pour l'exercice de sa mission ont été
restitués qui s'est assuré de leur
restitution
il a été licencié le 1er août donc il a
quitté effectivement le palais de
l'elysée le 1er août
son bureau a fait l'objet d'une
perquisition le 26 juillet et au cours
de cette perquisition réalisée par des
officiers de police judiciaire un
certain nombre d'objets ont été emportés
le 2 août
je vais retrouver leur précise que doux
dans l'après midi il a été procédé à un
inventaire de tout ce qui était dans le
bureau de monsieur benalla c'était à 16
heures
l'inventaire effectué contradictoirement
par le chef de cabinet et le commandant
militaire du palais donc tous les objets
qui était dans le bureau ont été
inventoriés et cet inventaire je lui
tiens à votre disposition des passeports
ni n'était pas parce qu'on n'y était pas
à compter du 20 juillet à compter du 20
juillet c'est à dire dix jours avant son
départ effectif
plusieurs mesures ont été prises pour
premièrement lui interdire l'accès à
tous les services de la présidence de la
république
deuxièmement pour vider son bureau en
effectuant un inventaire troisièmement
des mesures pour contrôler l'accès de
son bureau
tant qu'il était inoccupée quatrièmement
des mesures pour organiser la
restitution de ses effets personnels
alors très précisément de quelle mesure
s'agit-il le 20 juillet 2018
monsieur benalla et mis en garde à vue
le 20 juillet je demande aux commandants
militaires de prendre une note de
service pour tous les postes de contrôle
dans toutes les enceintes de l'elysée
pour interdire l'accès de ses services à
l'encontre de monsieur benalla et
l'instruction a été diffusée à tous les
services
le 26 juillet le 20 juillet pardon à
18h59
donc en conclusion mesdames et messieurs
je peux affirmer que monsieur benalla
n'est jamais venu à l'elysée après la
date de son licenciement
l'inventaire du bureau qui a été
effectué le 2 août confirme que les
passeports n'y était pas n'y était pas
alors j'anticipe peut-être une question
que vous allez certainement me poser
monsieur benalla prétend que c'est
passeport était resté à l'elysée et qui
lui aurait été remis par un agent de
l'elysée je réponds monsieur le
président voilà deux aidé beaucoup en
posant les questions ou même mais je
crois effectivement que nous rapportons
auraient été tentés de vous la poser
allez-y m'bia guerre je me plie à votre
honneur je souhaite s'il souhaite cinq
ans j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit
monsieur bénin et je dis haut et fort
ici que premièrement les mesures qui ont
été prises et que je viens de vous
détailler et pour lesquels il existe des
notes de service des courriers qui sont
à votre disposition permettent
d'affirmer que le passeport n'était pas
l'elysée mais surtout surtout je
voudrais vous donner l'information
extrêmement importante que je connais
depuis quelques heures et que monsieur
le ministre des affaires étrangères que
vous recevez tout à l'heure vous
confirmera à savoir que nous savons
aujourd'hui que monsieur benalla à
utiliser presque une vingtaine de fois
ces passeports entre le 1er août 2018
et le 31 décembre et la première
utilisation et du 1er août au 7 août et
les autres utilisations s'étendent sur
les mois d'octobre novembre et décembre
monsieur le président sur merci monsieur
le président monsieur le directeur je
vais vous poser de questions par rapport
aux as corps mais je voulais d'abord
faire quelques remarques suite au à vos
récentes déclarations présente premier
premier point je prends acte du fait que
vous avez déclaré que monsieur benalla
n'était pas revenu aucune fois à
l'elysée depuis son licenciement jambe
droite
deuxièmement eux
je m'étonne que le théorème le téléphone
théorème puisqu'il y en avait un seul
pour la chefferie de cabinet étaient
attribués à l'adjoint au chef de cabinet
et pourquoi pas au chef de cabinet
finalement puisqu'il y avait quatre
personnes
troisièmement je m'étonne véritablement
alors qu'il s'agit d'un système sécurisé
de haute protection que l'on ne se soit
aperçu qu'ils étaient manquants que le 4
octobre
c'est bien cela et que l'on se soit
aperçu le 4 octobre qu'il n'avait pas
servi depuis le 1er juillet donc
monsieur benalla disposer de cet outil
entre le 1er juillet et le 31 juillet il
a exercé diverses missions
nous le savons et il n'y en a pas été
fait usage
aucunement vous êtes sûr que cela est
conforme à la vérité quoi il n'a pas
il n'a pas servi bon pourquoi n'y at il
eu d'interrogation sur ce sujet que le 4
octobre alors que dès son départ
on aurait dû s'intéresser évidemment à
ce téléphone crypté huppert sécurisé
quatrièmement peu je m'étonne e te voir
que vous vous apercevez le 16 janvier
c'est à dire aujourd'hui vous avez dit
il ya quelques heures du fait que le
passeport diplomatique de monsieur
bénalia a été utilisé vingt fois voilà
quelqu'un qui n'est quand même pas
n'importe qui qui est un petit peu connu
qui a un pedigree dont on parle dans
l'actualité et qui franchit 20 frontière
sans que personne ne s'en rende compte
et voilà qu'il va voir en partant du bon
j'ai si mes informations sont exactes
monsieur le président du tchad avec
d'autres personnes et que alors qu'il
vient voir le président du tchad
quelque temps avant que le président de
la république fasse une visite
officielle on en est pas informé
l'elysée n'ait pas informé
est ce qu'il existe quand même une dsi
est ce qu'il existe un minimum de
services de renseignements je pose ces
questions parce que ce que vous avez dit
les appels première question
nous avons donc appris par
l'hebdomadaire que vous avez bien voulu
évoquer tout à l'heure que monsieur
benalla avait donc en plus de tout et
passeports diplômés divers passeport
diplomatique qui ont été remplacés etc
il avait un passeport de service
alors étiez vous au courant qu'il avait
un passeport de service à la demande de
qui et à quelles fins le ministère de
l'intérieur lui a attribué un passeport
de service
quelle utilité pouvait-il y avoir pour
ce membre des services de l'elysée
d'avoir un passeport de service dès lors
qu'il avait en plus deux passeports
diplomatiques il ya peut-être quelque
chose d'un peu inflationniste monsieur
le directeur
et ce passeport de service vous at il
été restitués ça c'est la première
question est alors deuxième et dernière
question
elle porte sur le premier le
renouvellement du premier passeport
diplomatique
la demande est formulée le jour monsieur
ben alla rentrer de ces quinze jours de
suspension pour chacun se souvient
imposé à titre de sanction pour son
comportement le 1er mai la demande
bizarrement et là c'est vraiment quelque
chose sur quoi nous voulons avoir des
explications
la demande n'est pas présentée par la
voie hiérarchique normal mais
directement par monsieur benalla sans en
référer à supérieur ni au service du
protocole et dans la lettre que vous
avez bien voulu nous écrire vous écrivez
vous écrivez n'ayant pas eu connaissance
de cette demande
l'autorité hiérarchique n'a pas été en
mesure de s'opposer à cette délivrance
alors que suite à sa suspension
monsieur benalla avait été déchargé des
déplacements internationaux donc il n'y
a plus aucune fonction qui justifie
qu'il est un passeport diplomatique il
en a plus lusage à ce moment là il
demande le renouvellement
mais au lieu de demander le
renouvellement par le service du
protocole et le demande directement je
suis parce qu'il le demande à quelqu'un
au ministère comment pouvez-vous ne pas
en être informé monsieur benalla a fait
une troisième demande et c'est celle que
vous évoquez dans votre question
il a fait une troisième deux mondes très
précisément le 23 mai 2018
cette demande il adressé directement je
dis bien directement sans passer par le
service du protocole et a fortiori un
échelon hiérarchique supérieur il
adressé directement aux services du quai
d'orsay qui a émis le passeport pour une
période de 4 ans et 4 mois et donc il a
été délivré le 20 septembre
n'en parlons il a été délivré le 24 mai
2018 en un jour non deux jours il a été
la demande a été faite le 23 il a été
délivré le 24 sans passer par le
protocole donc à la vitesse de l'éclair
quand même
la demande a été faite directement au
ministère des affaires étrangères
monsieur qu'électeur ça ne va pas
tout le monde le voit il n'a plus la
fonction l'état est un
le ministère des affaires étrangères il
n'est quand même pas sans lien avec
l'elysée l'elysée décide de lui
supprimer la vocation la fonction la
mission qui justifie ce passeport
le mystère des affaires étrangères ne le
sait pas il n'y a pas de transmissions
il n'y a pas d'information et il délivre
en même pas quarante huit heures un
passeport qui n'est pas réclamé par la
voix du service du protocole alors que
tous les plats sport qui sont établis
pour les personnels de l'elysée transit
nécessairement par le service du
protocole
enfin les mesures de réorganisation
interne non pas être notifiée à d'autres
ministères mais là on est confronté à un
comportement fautif d'un individu qui a
peut-être profité de failles du système
certainement mais si la hiérarchie
réelle connaissance de cette demande
bien évidemment elle s'y serait opposée
s'agissant du passeport de service
alors monsieur benalla a eu deux
passeports de service
le premier le premier lui a été délivré
bien avant qu'il soit dans les services
de l'elysée lorsqu'il était chef de
cabinet au sein de la délégation
interministérielle pour l'égalité des
chances des français d'outre-mer
passeport qui a été délivré le 29 août
2016 le deuxième passeport a été délivré
le 28 juin 2018 et
en termes de démarche engagée par
l'elysée lorsque monsieur benalla a
quitté ses fonctions le jour même ou
plutôt la veille le 30 juillet 2018
le 30 juillet 2008 il a été demandé au
ministère de l'intérieur car c'est lui
qui gère les passeports de service
d'invalider ses deux passeports
je tiens attestation d'invalidation à
votre disposition donc les passeports de
service que détenait monsieur benalla au
moment où il a quitté l'elysée ont été
validé
le jour même le jour même 21 juillet le
et cette année la validation figurent
dans la base des titres électroniques
sécurisés ce qui a pour conséquence que
lorsqu'ils sont utilisés au passage d'un
poste de frontière
ils sont signalés comme invalide ce
banal a été mis en demeure de restituer
de restituer ses deux passeports par un
courrier du chef de cabinet du président
d'un public qui lui a été adressée le 21
août le 21 août 2018 donc trois semaines
après son départ il n'ayant pas obtenu
de réponse à ce courrier
j'ai moi même adressé un courrier au
ministère de l'intérieur le 10 octobre
10 octobre 2018 pour lui demander de
poursuivre toutes les démarches pour
récupérer ces passeports des passeports
ont été rendus au ministère de
l'intérieur
plutôt le deuxième passeport a été rendu
au ministère de l'intérieur le 11
janvier et
le premier passeport celui qui le
détenait du fait de ses fonctions de
chef de cabinet auprès de la délégation
interministérielle en 2016 devrait être
restitué dans les jours qui viennent
donc monsieur monsieur monsieur monsieur
le rapporteur si vous le permettez tout
ça les démarches pour invalider les
passeports est à dire faire en sorte
qu'ils ne puissent pas être utilisés ont
été faites la veille de son départ va
l'elysée et ensuite il ya eu plusieurs
courriers plusieurs courrier lui
demandant de l'est resté alors il n'y a
pas eu effectivement de d'application
mais nous sommes dans un état de droit
et il n'appartient pas au directeur de
cabinet de l'élysée de désigner un
service de police pour aller chez les
personnes récupérer des passeports il ya
des procédures et en l'occurrence les
procédures ont été suivies à la lettre
alors j'ai encore une question là dessus
vous dites que vous nous dites que le
passeport de service a été peu sollicité
le 28 juin c'est ça dans des livres et
des livres et le 28 juin je voulais tout
simplement vous demander si la demande a
été faite par l'intermédiaire des
services de l'elysée ou directement par
l'intéressé parce que si c'est par les
services de l'elysée
je me mets à la place du service s'il a
déjà obtenu deux passeports
diplomatiques il pourrait peut-être
s'interroger sur la question de savoir
s'il faut en plus de monde à passeport
de service
celle ci monsieur benalla disposerait de
pouvoirs étendus votre question me
permet d'apporter un nouvel élément qui
vous permettra de cerner la personnalité
de monsieur bénard pour obtenir ce
deuxième passeport mais ce benalla
adressée au ministère de l'intérieur une
note
dactylographiée avant tête du chef de
cabinet une notes non signées de façon
manuscrite
manuscrite et donc quand on a lu ce
document
bien évidemment on a demandé au chef de
cabinet c'est lui qui avait adressé ce
document au ministère de l'intérieur
et il n'est pas l'auteur de cette note
donc soupçonnant une falsification faite
par monsieur benalla nous avons signalé
ce fait au procureur de la république
par un article 40 à quelle date ce matin
oui donc c'est à dire que vous avez
découpage j'essaie de comprendre un le
28 juin le passeport de service et
délivrer donc il des demandes et
antérieurement et il est demandé par un
papier du chef de cabinet a en tête du
chef de cabinet dont le chef de cabinet
n'a pas connaissance
ce document et arrive au ministère de
l'intérieur il ya donc une sorte d'
usage de faux quand quelque chose comme
cela
selon la cnil enquête qui le dira oui il
arrive au ministère de l'intérieur et le
ministre de l'intérieur des livres ou
très rapidement un passeport de service
et et vous donne et et vous ne sert pour
un coût l'article 40 prospère et on a
déjà vu qu'ils avaient été invoquées
le 28 décembre le 9 janvier sur ce fait
là il faut attendre le 9 janvier pour
corey saisissiez le parquet en vertu de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
alors que parce que vous n'avez
découvert le fait qu'il s'agissait en
quelque sorte d'un faux que très
récemment
alors quand l'avez-vous découvre lorsque
monsieur benalla quitté l'elysée la
priorité était d'avalide et les
passeports de crs étaient d'invalider
les astros qui ne puisse plus être
utilisés ce qui a été fait veille de son
départ
à partir de là est ce que vous saviez
qu'il avait un passeport de service
puisqu'il a demandé au ministère de
l'intérieur avec un papier en tête sans
que le chef de cabinet en et été
informés comment l'elysée a pu savoir
qu'il avait un passeport de service seul
ministre de l'intérieur qui nous a
signalé en disant vous l'a signalé à
quelle date le la validation a eu lieu
le 30
le 30 juillet donc c'était à cette
époque
et s'il vous a signalé et le 30 juillet
vous avez pris connaissance du fait
qu'il y avait un document non non non
bien vous en avez pris connaissance à
qu'elle vient plus tard
moi je les ai appris récemment voilà
dans le courant de l'automne
mais à ce moment là j'ai considéré que
le problème était réglé puisque les
passeports d'une part était invalidée
depuis le 30 juillet et ensuite toutes
les démarches avaient été faites pour
obtenir leur restitution
oui mais c'est récemment lorsqu au vu de
l' enquête préliminaire ouverte en le
broker d'art public sur la base d' abus
de confiance et d'utilisation
frauduleuse des titres que j'ai souhaité
aux verts sz
cet élément supplémentaire au dossier
parce que on est confronté un monsieur
qui visiblement utilise régulièrement
défaut pour tenir un certain nombre de
titre officiel de glace j'observe que
après avoir pris connaissance à
l'automne du fait qu'il y ait un faux
documents ou un document utilisé de
manière fallacieuse et qui utilise à son
insu le titre du chef de cabinet vous ne
saisissez le
le parquet outils de l'article 40 que le
9 janvier disons que l' enquête
préliminaire ouverte par le procureur
l'a été le 29 décembre
donc c'est un élément supplémentaire qui
la nourrir un dossier qui ont na vi est
déjà très lourd
bien sûr la suite nous sommes d'accord
et je répète la priorité pour nous est
aidé à valider ces passeports
merci monsieur le directeur tout cas
nous constatons que parmi les effets
bénéfiques de nos auditions il ya tout
de même un certain nombre de décisions
qu'elles permettent d'accélérer rendre
aux deux questions
si vous permettez germain a également
apporté quelques éléments aux
observations qui ont été faites
monsieur le rapporteur vous nous
demandez pourquoi nous n'avons pas été
informés de tous les déplacements de
monsieur benalla déplacement au cours
desquelles il a utilisé le passeport
diplomatique
les chefs d'état hamad je n'en sais rien
non mais vous ne savez pas grand chose
mais c'est quand même étonnant je suis
et mois de mars sur le reporter non je
hais ce que j'écoute et je suis désolé
mais je peux vous assurer que j'ai
consacré beaucoup d'heures à préparer
cet entretien et que je suis venu avec
le souci de vous donner le maximum
d'informations
alors si vous retenez de mes
interventions que la maison n'est pas
tenue je peux vous assurer que c'est fou
monsieur du fait monsieur présent merci
monsieur directeur j'ai une question
je crains que vous ayez déjà répondu à
cette question mais monsieur benalla
venait de dire à utiliser au moins à 20
reprises les passeports qu'ils avaient
conservée pour voyager savez-vous pour
quel usage il a fait ses voyages qu'il a
rencontrés et si vous ne savez pas parce
que je crois que vous avez dit que vous
ne saviez pas avez-vous diligente et
dansait déjà des procédures une enquête
je sais pas sous quelle que forme que
cela se représente pour en savoir un peu
plus merci merci cher collègue madame
eustache brinio
merci monsieur présidente qui sont très
très courte et peut-être un peu direct
monsieur le directeur vous me
pardonnerez un peu côté directrice de ma
question
vous nous avez apporté énormément
d'informations aujourd'hui certaines
sont parfois un peu stupéfiants je suis
là lorsque j'avais posé la question du
passeport avec beaucoup d'assurance
m'avaient dit qu'ils avaient laissé dans
son bureau
donc aujourd'hui une seule question
monsieur directeur pensez-vous
clairement votre âme et conscience que
monsieur benalla nous a menti lors de
son audition du mois de septembre
questions très directes raison très
simple c'est important que vous puissiez
apporter votre point de vue à ce sujet
et enfin monsieur kerrouche merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur de cabinet c'est pour être sûr
de bien comprendre vos propos et une
précision sur ce que vous avez déclarez
vous nous avez dit s'agissant des
passeports de monsieur benalla je vous
cite c'est un monsieur qui a utilisé
régulièrement défaut pour obtenir des
titres officiels
je dois savoir une chose très simple est
ce que vous faites référence à la lettre
dont vous avez parlé à en-tête du chef
de cabinet ou est ce que vous faites
référence à d'autres faculté qu'aurait
utilisé monsieur benalla pour travestir
des documents on m'a demandé si j'avais
dit que monsieur benalla est un menteur
non non non je n'ai pas employé ce terme
eux ce n'est pas à moi de
ah mais je ne sais pas moi de me
prononcer là dessus je suis le directeur
nous a dit tout à l'heure je vous ai
joué les as port n'était pas dans le
bureau et monsieur benhaddad nous a dit
qu'il était dans le bureau
voilà voilà monsieur le président je
j'ai parfaitement conscience que j'ai
pas répondu à toutes les questions bien
évidemment tous les documents note de
service courrier courriel que j'ai
évoquées voir d'autres sont à votre
disposition donc je pourrais vous les
faire parvenir via kerrouche voudrais
néanmoins pu obtenir une réponse cette
question c'est qu'est rouge serait dit
long c'était juste monsieur le directeur
de cabinet par rapport au passé pour
être sûrs que nous avons bien compris ce
que vous avez dit je vous le jeu je vous
répète vous avez dit que s'agissant de
monsieur rénald c'est un monsieur qui ce
que vous avez déclaré qui a
régulièrement utilisé des faux pour
obtenir des titres officiels
est ce que ces circonstances ya la
lettre dont vous nous avez parlé ce qui
allait de ses quelque chose c'est un
comportement général non j'y suis allé
un peu loin dans mon affirmation
ce dont je suis sûre moment où nous
parlons aussi dessinateur c'est que le
document qui lui a permis d'avoir son
deuxième passeport de service est un
faux ça j'en suis sûr c'est sûr avec cet
individu ou découvre tous les jours des
choses nouvelles et après à les
révélations de patrick strzoda c'est
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur qui a dû s'expliquer pour la
seconde fois devant la haute assemblée
il a notamment été interrogé sur les
mesures prises par son ministère pour
empêcher les déplacements d'alexandre
benalla je vous propose de l'écouter
nous avons tout à l'heure avec le
directeur du cabinet du président de la
république poser la question de savoir
si au fond compte tenu de ce qui s'était
passé il y avait eu une sorte de cellule
de crise organisée pour veiller point
par point à ce que tous les attributs de
sa fonction soit rapidement restitués
par monsieur benalla et qu'en tout cas
il ne puisse plus s'en servir
et là ce sont
des cadres des deux ministères qui se
renvoient la balle pendant plusieurs
semaines sans que la police de l'air et
des frontières soit alertée qu'il y
avait une possibilité que monsieur
benalla utilise un passeport
diplomatique que qu'on lui avait demandé
de restituer des le mode lui c'est vous
comprenez notre préoccupation là dessus
monsieur le ministre je comprends votre
préoccupation mais d'abord vous évoquez
les ministres encore faut-il être saisie
avoir l'information pour que les
ministres puissent intervenir
tel n'est pas le cas qu'est ce qui se
passe avec un passeport diplomatique
vous le présentez à l'aubette vous êtes
contrôlés à l'aubette du contrôle de la
paf est une application covadis qui
reconnaît votre nom et qui interroge de
base le fichier des personnes
recherchées dans un premier temps et un
second fichier c'est un anglicisme
health ltd qui va interroger un
troisième fichier qui s'appelle fauve
est ce qu est un fichier qui supporte
donc les fichiers volés ou perdus mais
cela ne fonctionne pas pour les
passeports invalidés j'ai bien dit pour
fovez des fichiers les passeports qui
sont volés ou perdus le cas
d'invalidation n'existe pas aujourd'hui
dans notre système numérique
électronique et donc ya pas de base il
n'existe pas de base qui permet d'avoir
cette information centralisée sur la
totalité des passeports je sais
parfaitement au nom du ministère de
l'intérieur
et m une information sur un titre qui
est émis par le ministère de l'intérieur
et qui du coup à un moment donné va être
gérée par la police de l'air et des
frontières
ça n'est pas le cas pour les passeports
diplomatiques donc c'est ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre notre système est très
opérationnelle sur l'ensemble des
passeports on y reviendra si vous le
souhaitez il ya quatre types de
passeports qui peuvent être émis par le
ministère de l'intérieur sur lequel
notre système numérique est assez simple
et assez efficace
en l'espèce pour les passeports
diplomatiques qui en plus ne sont pas
des passeports biométriques et qui n'ont
pas le même niveau d'information il
n'est pas possible aujourd'hui de dire
on interdit
alors on préfère un signalement
personnel mais sauf que ce ne serait pas
légale monsieur le président d'avoir
parce que monsieur ben alla jusqu'à
nouvel ordre n'a pas été condamné et qui
a pas eu de condamnation d' interdiction
de sortie du territoire
c'est déjà une information qui est
importante et de nous au niveau de la
police de l'air et des frontières jeudi
nous avec un nous évidemment collectif
nous ne sommes pas en mesure de décider
qui même s'il est médiatisé que ou pas
sortir du territoire et nous n'avons pas
l'information
quand le ministère des affaires
étrangères et mais un passeport
diplomatique
tout comme nous n'avons pas
l'information je parle en général du
fait que le passeport diplomatique n'a
plus sa fonction ou sa vocation à être
utilisé ou pas utilisés j'espère être
clair sur ce sujet mais je voudrais que
les choses soient claires le ministère
de l'intérieur assume l'émission et la
gestion de quatre types de passeports et
donc aujourd'hui on a un système qui
permet de le suivre
par contre pour les passeports
diplomatiques nous n'avons pas
l'information en amont
il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de possibilité
de dire un passeport est désactivé parce
que la personne a perdu sa fonction
d'origine et donc le ministre de
l'intérieur s'il n'a pas l'information
et s'il n'a pas une réquisition sur ce
sujet n'est pas en mesure d'interdire
son utilisation
voilà je veux que les choses soient
claires sur cette question là je sais
d'un principe qui à nouveau qui est
conscient par contre on a un problème
technique s'est gelé dit on a
aujourd'hui un dispositif qui remonte à
un décret de 2005
on a aujourd'hui pour les passeports de
service on a aujourd'hui des dispositifs
techniques et technologiques sur les qui
permettent de gérer les différents
passeport qui ne permettent pas en fait
d'analyser la situation d'un passeport
diplomatique qui n'auraient pas été
perdu ou qui n'aurait pas été volé donc
qui aurait fait l'objet d'une
déclaration devant la police pour pertes
ou pour vol et ou la simple information
de l'administration de tutelle ne nous
permet pas de dire il a perdu sa
fonction
nous ne sommes pas nous autorités
judiciaires qui avait cette capacité
donc dès l'information dé ce constat et
je dois vous avouer que ce concert est
assez récent c'est la première fois
qu'ils se produit semble-t-il dans nos
relations entre les deux ministères des
ce constat nous avons décidé avec jean
yves le drian qu'un groupe de travail
fasse en sorte qu'on puisse trouver des
solutions techniques
cette situation n'était jamais arrivé et
nous trouverons une solution assez
rapide pour qu'elles ne se reproduisent
pas
merci monsieur 2010
madame jourda merci monsieur le
président monsieur mist une série de
questions techniques sur les passeports
diplomatiques et les contrôles auxquels
ils donnent lieu
j'aurais souhaité vous puissiez nous
préciser dans un premier temps quel type
de contrôles sont effectués à la
frontière sur les personnes détentrices
d'un passeport diplomatique et un
contrôle des fichiers de police et
notamment du fichier des personnes
recherchées
le cas échéant ces contrôles donne-t-il
lieu à un enregistrement est il possible
de retracer par ces enregistrements le
passage d'une personne détentrice d'un
passeport diplomatique à la frontière et
au regard de ces éléments que vous avez
d'ores et déjà dû contrôler avez vous
pris depuis lors les décisions pour
améliorer éventuellement la formation
des services sur les entrées et sorties
du territoire français ce ministre
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure le processus
le passeport est présente et quel que
soit le pass pour le passeport
diplomatique et présentées il est
contrôlé l'homme était dûment élu avec
ses références par une application
covadis celle ci interrogent
immédiatement de fichiers fichier des
personnes qui sont recherchés et le smtd
le slt décès n'est fait d'algorithmes va
interroger le fichier fort le fichier
fop lui traite des fichiers volés ou
perdus
trente quatre raisons aucun des trois
fichiers naïté c'est à dire qu'aucun des
trois fichiers ne dit attention il ya un
problème parce que vous aimez dallas
n'est dans aucun des trois fichiers
c'est normal qu'ils ne soient pas de
fichier des personnes recherchées il ne
l'est pas c'est normal qu'ils ne soient
pas dans le fichier international ltd
et c'est normal qu'ils ne soient pas à
ce moment là dans le fichier qui
supporte les fichiers les passeports
volés ou perdus parce que lille n'est
pas enregistrée comme un passeport volé
ou perdu
donc tu me manques ça ne dit pas le
fonctionnaire qui contrôle dit merci
monsieur au revoir et la personne peut
passer quelle qu'elle soit le cadre d'un
vie médiation je vous le rappelle n'est
pas prévu dans notre dispositif on
m'avait posé une seconde question savoir
s'il existait une base une sorte de
fichier qui recenserait tous les
mouvements
aujourd'hui ça n'existe pas par contre
il ya la possibilité de faire des
contrôles sont nombreux on est passé
mais cela se fait sur réquisition
judiciaire
et ça tombe bien parce que stylée
services du ministère de l'intérieur
voir le miz intérieur de la possibilité
d'avoir un fichier et l'accès la
totalité des mouvements de l'ensemble
des français qui partent à l'étranger
je pense que ce serait une
démocratique que le président de la
commission des lois ne manquerait pas de
me rappeler à l'ordre
et donc aujourd'hui je ne me permettrais
c'était un clin d'oeil amical
monsieur le président et donc il faut
avoir en tête que par contre on a la
possibilité de faire ses recherches mais
c'est sur réquisition judiciaire
évidemment le ministre de l'intérieur
n'est pas en mesure de le faire c'est
pour ça que je ne suis pas en mesure de
vous dire monsieur pénale à utiliser son
passeport tel jour à telle heure en
passant à t-elle guichet de contrôle de
ta l'aéroport ça n'est pas d'abord n'y a
pas eu de demande judiciaire sur ce
sujet là et je ne dispose pas d'un outil
de ce type là j'espère avoir été clair
on vous répondre merci monsieur le
ministre
che président sueur merci monsieur le
président de questions encore s'agissant
du passeport de service de monsieur
benalla dont nous avons appris
l'existence comme vous même peut-être
hier soir mais vous étiez sans doute
mieux informer que nous monsieur le
ministre
donc il nous a été indiqué que la
délivrance des passeports de service
était géré par votre ministère
nous nous sommes posé la question
suivante
ce passeport de service at il été
demandé officiellement par les services
de l'elysée ou directement par le
monsieur benalla est ce que eux ils vous
êtes apparu utile de donner un passeport
de délivrer un passeport de service à
quelqu'un qui disposait par ailleurs de
deux passeports diplomatiques
quelle est l utilité sinon une
collection de passeport et enfin lorsque
monsieur banal isles
lorsqu'il a été mis fin à ses fonctions
par un licenciement
est-ce que ce passeport de service vous
a été restituée et s'il ne vous avait
pas été restitués tel diligence
avez-vous accompli afin qu'il le fut
fait une seconde et dernière question
mais croyez vous aviez déjà posé deux
qui s'annonce à c'était une question à
traiter c'est un ensemble monsieur le
président est là la dernière question à
un seul point d'interrogation elle n'a
qu'un seul point d'interrogation
nous avons eu le sentiment qu'à l'elysée
monsieur ban à la faisait partie d'un
petit groupe qui avait pour objectif de
repenser l'organisation de la sécurité
du chef de l'état et monsieur benalla a
déclaré au journal du dimanche qu'il lui
semblait préférable de dissocier ces
missions eux ou cette réflexion du
ministère de l'intérieur
cette déclaration vous a sans doute
étonnés et je voulais savoir quelle est
votre appréciation
sinon ce tracé assez fait qu'ils ont été
rapportés sous entre guillemets dans la
presse voilà c'est fini monsieur
précision sera éthique
alors j'ai commencé par la dernière vous
disant que l'instant présent je me fiche
un peu des opinions technique de
monsieur bénard assure l'organisation de
la sécurité à la fois du ministère de
l'intérieur et de la présidence de la
république
et pour tout vous dire je n'ai pas lu
cette remarque là mais c'est libre il
est libre de s'exprimer sur le clan des
libres 2 500 m me fait penser à mon
attention n'a pas été encore dans
d'autres fonctions monsieur ministre
voilà mais bon je préfère vous dire que
ça n'a pas vocation à peser sur les
décisions que je serai amené à prendre
comme ministre je voudrais vous dire sur
les passeports de service qui eux
relèvent du ministère de l'intérieur que
j'ai le sentiment que toute diligence a
été faite par nos services alors je vais
préciser le fait que d'abord monsieur
bénard à deux pavés de passeports de
service
le premier avait été demandée le 29 août
à l'époque
une réglementation qui prévoit cela il
était dans ses fonctions de chef de
cabinet du délégué interministériel pour
l'égalité des chances des français
d'outre-mer nous étions en 2016 c'était
la mandature d'avant et dans ce cadre là
il a eu un premier passeport puis il a
effectivement demandé un second
passeport de service la demande date du
18 juin 2018 et le passeport a été émis
le 28 juin 2018 pourquoi deux passeports
peut-être que la question a été posée
tout à l'heure à monsieur le directeur
de cabinet du président vous savez qui
est une doctrine qui existe un bestiaire
de passeports ordinaires
on demande de passeport dont certaines
circonstances soit en cas de visa
incompatibles d'un pays à l'autre ça
doit arriver soit pour des raisons
professionnelles vous voyagez beaucoup
et le temps d'instruction pour un visa
fait que vous me demandez ça justifie de
passeport mais paca mais je vais
répondre à ce volet là mais je voudrais
que je pourrai 6 quelle est la règle
mais c'est déjà assez rare parce que je
sais pas vous mais pour ce qui me
concerne je n'ai qu'un passeport mais
n'en est qu'un monsieur le ministre
c'est pour ça et donc pour nous c'est ça
ensuite qu'il est de passeports
diplomatiques c'est une information que
les services du ministère de l'intérieur
non pas que les choses soient claires
nous n'avons pas accès à la base de
données du ministère des affaires
étrangères nous n'avons aucune
information
si ce n'est la déclaration de tel ou tel
requérants il faut que vous ayez en tête
que nous émettons 6000 passeport de
service par an une fille de vous dire
que ce soit celui de monsieur benhadda
ou celui de n'importe qui ça ne remonte
pas au ministre a fait trois mois que je
suis en fonctions que j'avais vu passer
une saisine de demande sur ce volet là
j'ai toute confiance sociale donc la
règle est la suivante n'ayant pas
connaissance du fait qu'il ait deux
passeports diplomatiques
le fonctionnaire qui a instruit le
dossier ne s'est pas alerté de ce sujet
là après vous avez fait une un
commentaire que je serai pas à partager
monsieur le rapporteur sur le fait de
l'utilité de la requête placer sur
lequel j'ai un doute
ce que je peux vous dire et ça me
permettrait pendant une des questions
c'est que monsieur benalla à restituer
via son avocat le 11 janvier
l'un des deux passeports de service pour
le ministère nous avons fait toutes
diligences c'est à dire que
dès que nous avons eu connaissance alors
je rappelle la règle normalement fait
que jeudi qu'il n'avait 6000 par an la
règle est que normalement c'est
l'autorité employeurs qui a fait l'objet
qui a porté la demande de passeport de
service qui a la responsabilité de
récupérer le passeport de service c'est
pas le ministère de l'intérieur une
raison simple c'est que si un
collaborateur peut justifier de son
statut pour demander un passeport de
service mais perd son statut
nous n'en avons pas connaissance la
personne et de samba démissionne et muté
et licenciés selon tous les cas de
figure qu'on peut imaginer
nous n'avons pas connaissance de cela
donc le décret de 2005 qui organise cela
prévoit que c'est l'autorité
administrative de rattachement qui a
signé la demande qui doit récupérer le
passeport et le restituer au ministère
de l'intérieur
ça c'est la règle qui découlent de ce
décret de 2005 toutefois dans le cas de
monsieur benalla le ministère de
l'intérieur a effectivement entendu
parler de la situation professionnelle
de monsieur bénard et dès le 30 juillet
à débrancher
je reprends mon terme évoqué tout à
l'heure les deux passeports de monsieur
benalla donc ils ont perdu ils ont perdu
hélas nous savons faire ils ont perdu
immédiatement dès le 30 juillet leur
capacité d' usage mais monsieur benalla
ne les avaient pas restitués et n'en est
restitué qu'un des 2 le 11 janvier et
nous avons via son avocat et nous avons
immédiatement envoyé une lettre
recommandée à son avocat pour lui dire
que c'était bien qu'ils nous en est
restituée
on l'avait sollicité à plusieurs
reprises en mai qu'il en manquait un
second et on lui a demandé de renvoyer
le second espère avoir été précis vous
n'avez pas répondu sur les les
conditions dans lesquelles ce passeport
de service a été sollicitée car il a été
question d'une lettre à en-tête du chef
de cabinet vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de cela une lettre en tête du
chef de cabine et non signé et dont le
chef de cabinet n'était pas informée
cela n'a pas éveillé l'attention de
votre ministère de vos collaborateurs
non une raison simple c'est que c'est
lui âge la lettre en question portent la
mention alors je rappelle que l' usage
d'ailleurs dans ce dossier c'est assez
intéressant
monsieur benalla s'adresse directement à
nos services et demande
aspord il peut même passeport de service
nos services réagissent ils disent on
peux pas vous le délivre et il faut que
ce soit votre autorité hiérarchique qui
le demandent donc il se passe quelques
jours et il nous remet une lettre qui
est un original signé et donc originale
signée c'est celle intitulée qu'on met
sur la mention si elle n'est pas signé
on vous envoie le document c'est un
document de transmission administratif
avec voilà les sauf que c'est là où j'ai
entendu alors pour être honnête j'étais
aux questions d'actualité à l'assemblée
nationale j'ai entendu la fin de
l'audition de monsieur strzoda j'ai
entendu sa réponse est donc il a précisé
cela donc le document en question que je
vais remettre au président sous réserve
voilà de ce que je dis tout ça parce que
là on est vraiment dans le ton ce qui
fait l'objet d'une instruction
judiciaire mais je veux remettre ce
document sans difficulté ce porte la
mention c'est un papier à en-tête
présence de la république qui fait
demande d'un second passeport de service
qui précise le cadre pour lequel il est
demandé je vous disais tout à l'heure
pourquoi un second voilà il est précisé
que c'est lié au fait qu'ils se
déplacent à l'étranger assez
régulièrement et que c'est pour des
raisons impérieuses de services formule
assez classique et on a la mention
originale signée mentions
traditionnelles donc à ce moment là mais
qui n'est pas signée réellement à ce
moment là pour le service il a son
document le chef de service
en l'espèce le chef de cabinet de
quelqu'un qui demande à fait la démarche
le dossier est complet en une semaine un
peu moins le dossier est émis et donc il
a eu dans ce cadre là
son la formation nous d'un point de vue
personnel ça reste dans le dossier
dossier qui sera remis à la justice
intégralement si c'est nécessaire
monsieur le comte
si monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
deux questions monsieur benalla et est
connu par tous les français et les
françaises depuis le mois de juillet
dernier
est ce que le fait qu'on apprenne qu'il
est passé vingt fois depuis le mois de
juillet la frontière avec un passeport
diplomatique ne vous interroge pas sur
le fait que si vous n'avez pas eu
d'information de la police de l'air et
des frontières sur le fait qu' il ya eu
des passages parce que j'imagine qu'ils
l'ont reconnu ils ont pu s'interroger
sur l'usagé d'un passeport diplomatique
est ce que l évaluation vous faites du
fonctionnement de la paf si une
information de cette nature ne vous êtes
pas remonté du tout enfin compte tenu
chez un peu abasourdi de ce que vous
nous dites sur les passeports
diplomatiques et sur le fait que sur
sarthe que si le détenteur du passeport
n'est plus en position légitime de le
détenir
on ne peut pas l'annuler et la question
que je vous pose assez à votre votre
estimation
est ce que ces passeports sont
aujourd'hui suffisamment sécurisé j'ai
une question sur l'utile plus globale
sur l'utilisation du passeport
diplomatique
je vous ai dit que nous n'avions pas
connaissance quand ils utilisent tout
comme heureusement les policiers qui
voit pas c'est un individu même s'il est
connu
même s'il est connu qui fait l'objet
d'une procédure au delà de la situation
médiatique qu'il a connus ne font pas
remonter l'information au ministère de
l'intérieur et au ministre de
l'intérieur et heureusement et policiers
fonctionne dans un cadre procédural
précis ils agissent systématiquement
lorsqu'il ya une alerte et donc si par
exemple il avait été inscrit au fichier
des personnes recherchées
ça aurait fait un hit comme on dit et
donc ça aurait déclenché une procédure
et j'aurais eu l'information mais là ce
n'est pas le cas il n'est pas dans aucun
fichier
il n'a pas d'interdiction de sortie du
territoire et donc y produit un document
qui reste légale alors qu'il n'a plus le
droit de l'utiliser c'est la différence
référence et le fait qu'il n'ait plus le
droit d'utiliser comme tous les
bénéficiaires d'un passeport
diplomatique
et je le dis d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui
pouvaient m'entendre ici ou ailleurs qui
aurait un passeport diplomatique qu'ils
auraient études dans des fonctions mais
global qui est voilà en fait on oublie
de rendre souvent alors que quand on
prend un passeport diplomatique comme
ministre gt dotée d'un pasteur de
pratique vous signe un papier comme quoi
vous vous engagez à restituer le
passeport diplomatique et donc du coup
c'est toute la difficulté est là il n'a
pas le droit de l'utiliser mais pour
l'agent qu'il contrôle
il attend qu il a encore un caractère
légal tant qu'il n'est pas inscrit sur
les différents fichiers et donc je le
redis évidemment monsieur benalla
n'était pas sous surveillance
il s'est déplacé il est libre de se
déplacer et le ministère de l'intérieur
n'a pas vocation à enregistrer ses
sorties du territoire particulièrement
et en faire état au ministre de
l'intérieur
je vous dirais heureusement et donc
c'est la remarque aussi la réponse que
je peux faire sur les 20 passages à
l'ats auprès de la paf la paf n'a pas à
le faire remonter
voilà monsieur buffet si monsieur le
ministre monsieur strzoda nous a indiqué
tout à l'heure que monsieur b dallas
avait utilisé à 20 reprises au moins les
passeports qu'ils avaient conservées
illégalement d'ailleurs pour se rendre
entre le propos se déplacer entre le 1er
août et le 31 décembre dernier
savez vous où il est allé et pour quelle
raison il a fait ses voyages si vous ne
le savez pas avez-vous diligenter des
instructions aux services pour qu'ils
puissent déterminer la destination et
les motifs de ses déplacements ses
ministres alors monsieur le président
vous dire que pour ce qui relève du
ministère de l'intérieur des titres émis
par le ministère je pense que nous avons
fait mieux que des vérifications
systématiques et deux interventions
rapides
je vous ai rappelé que pour les deux
passeports de service qui avait été
menée par le ministère ils ont été et
l'autre annuler les procédures ont été
signalés nous ont saisis l'elysée
immédiatement pour qu'il réclame la
restitution des passeports et dès le 30
juillet il n'était plus opérants je vous
signale que c'est le premier route
qu'eux
il ya eu cela mais on a considéré lisez
comme un employeur comme un autre et on
a fait la procédure sur ce sujet
deuxième élément pour les passeports
diplomatiques il n'appartient pas au
ministère de l'intérieur de les gérer et
nous ne sommes pas en mesure de le faire
ensuite savoir si compte tenu des
voyages nous avons dirigé une enquête
non parce que la police judiciaire n'est
pas sous l'autorité du milieu intérieur
à l'autorité de la justice et donc il
faut qu'ils saisine judiciaire et donc
si j'avais fait cela si j'avais demandé
aux services d'essayer ce que
j'expliquais on procède tout à l'heure
de m'identifier les déplacements etc
j'aurais juste enfreint toutes les
règles qui organise la police dans ce
pays et toutes les doigts que vous
pouvez voter donc la réponse est non sur
les informations pour les voyages et non
je n'ai pas diligenté des enquêtes pour
connaître les destinations de monsieur
benalla pendant cette période je
rappelle que monsieur bénard est la
seule responsabilité de la police et
donc de miser l'intérieur c'est monsieur
veda n'est pas aujourd'hui interdits de
sortie du territoire
il est libre de voyager et donc nous
n'avons pas vocation au ministère de
l'intérieur à connaître des voyages des
gens qui sont libres de voyager
heureusement dernière auditionné par la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale jean
yves le drian le ministre des affaires
étrangères il est revenu sur les
difficultés rencontrées par son
ministère pour obtenir et la restitution
par alexandre benalla de ces passeports
diplomatiques je vous propose de
réécouter les temps forts de son
audition comment il est possible après
la tempête provoquée par cette affaire
banana que une pilotage
aussi peu ferme était mis en oeuvre par
ce que il ya une première lettre
recommandée non suivies d'effet il y en
a une deuxième année même pas retirée il
faut ensuite attendre le 8 novembre vous
que le ministère de l'intérieur soit
saisi et il semble qu'il y ait des
discussions entre les bureaux de la
place beauvau et du quai d'orsay assez
longue et finalement on constate
qu'aucune consigne donnée à la police de
l'air et des frontières pour que
l'utilisation illégale d'un passeport
diplomatique à la sortie du territoire
soit empêcher autant comprends très bien
que citoyen français qui est franchi les
contrôles de la police de l'air et des
frontières pour se déplacer avec son
passeport
comme tout un chacun ne puisse pas être
interceptées si il n'est pas poursuivi
par la justice par exemple autant il
nous paraît difficile de comprendre
comment les comment les les dispositions
ont pu ne pas être prises beaucoup plus
tôt pour empêcher à tout le moins à la
sortie du territoire
l'utilisation du passeport diplomatique
alors que la commission des lois avait
posé la question lors de ses auditions
de l'été et que par conséquent le sujet
n'était pas un sujet qui était resté
dans l'ombre c'est un sujet qui avait
été publiquement mis sur la table il
nous semble que dans ce type de cas il
est surprenant que on ait pu arriver à
ce ce
résultat qu'il ait fallu attendre de
nouvelles informations de presse
révélant usage abusif du passeport pour
que des nouvelles initiatives soient
prises après les premières initiatives
qui l'avait été quelques mois plus tôt
et donc c'est la première question que
je souhaitais vous vous posez monsieur
le ministre c'est au fond est-ce que
vous êtes convaincu je suppose que vous
l'êtes mais nous le sommes moins que
toutes les diligences ont été fait pour
empêcher les âges de ce passeport qui
n'était pas restitué malgré votre montre
il y a eu de deux phénomènes
concomitants
il ya d'abord le fait que dès que le
licenciement de l'intéressé a été connue
j'ai demandé l'application de ce qu'il
avait lui-même signé
c'est à dire lorsqu'on a un passeport
diplomatique ou laurent et le passeport
diplomatique et pour lui était d'une
durée de cinq ans correspondait à sa
mission et a pas tellement la mission
est interrompue il faut rendre et j'ai
engagé la procédure d'elle quatre jours
avant même licenciements effectifs mais
dès qu'on savait que le licenciement est
effectué
c'est la première démarche qu'il
convient de faire considérant qu'ils
avaient le mois d'août que le délai d'un
mois de réponse man est un délai
convenable j'ai réitéré ma demande
ensuite auprès de l'intéressé qui n'a
pas répondu
à partir de ce moment là nous sommes
rentrés dans la logique de la procédure
d'invalidation qui comme je le dis dans
mon propos introductif et n'a jamais eu
lieu
c'était la première fois c'est un
précédent que l'on décide d'annuler le
passeport
la question ce n'est pas l'annulation du
passeport c'est surtout j'y reviendrai
je pense l'annulation de busage c'était
c'est ça le sujet et à la demande du
cabinet du président de la république et
nous étions déjà dans cette
interrogation nous mêmes nous avons
engagé des discussions avec le ministère
de l'intérieur à partir 2 15e du 15
octobre pour parce que nous avons reçu
la lettre du directeur de cabinet du
président de la république le 16 octobre
partir du 16 octobre avec le ministère
de l'intérieur pour procéder à la
validation du passeport et nous nous
avons il ya eu des échanges internes qui
était rendue compliquée par le fait
qu'il y a comme je l'aï dit au début une
mauvaise articulation entre les deux
outils informatiques nécessaires parce
qu'il suffit pas de dire on va invalider
il faut ensuite que la police de l'air
et des frontières là où se font les
contrôles soient informés du fait que ce
passeport soit invalidée et donc lui a
eu les échanges internes qui ont abouti
le 8 novembre par une démarche de ma
part demandant là l'invalidation au
ministère de l'intérieur
ensuite il y a eu d'autres échanges
entre les différents services alors j'ai
dit j'hésite des échanges de mails parce
que tu es un cas tout à fait nouveau qui
était posée comme n'y avait pas
d'interconnexion et en particulier pas
de lien direct technique entre l'outil
informatique du ministère des affaires
étrangères et l' agence nationale des
titres sécurisés
il a fallu agir autrement le nice à
l'intérieur nous a demandé des
informations supplémentaires que nous
avons mobilisé et il y à une deuxième
demande de d'invalidation le 19 décembre
19 décembre de notre part auprès
toujours auprès des milices à
l'intérieur pour apporter les éléments
supplémentaires qu'il nous avait
sollicités et pour le faire valider ce
qui aboutit à une invalidation transmise
à l'ensemble des
services concernés c'est-à-dire à la
fois les services nationaux mais aussi
aux schengen interpol et le service des
passeports volent des documents de
documents volés au niveau international
pour aboutir à cette décision voilà le
premier sujet mais votre question en
appelle une autre
à partir du moment où j'ai eu la
conviction que l'intéressé avait utilisé
son passeport diplomatique pour se
rendre à l'étranger
j'ai estimé qu' il était dans une
situation illégale et j'ai saisi le
procureur j'ai eu cette conviction par
le voyage au tchad
c'est à dire le 24 décembre à partir du
24 décembre et 7 concordants des
informations que j'ai eu la certitude
que l'intéressé avait dans son
déplacement au tchad utiliser son
passeport diplomatique et donc à partir
de cette certitude là j'ai saisi le
procureur de la république
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
est entendu que la saisine du procureur
de la république permette de poursuivre
le détenteur d'un passeport diplomatique
et mina a droit mais ne permet pas dans
l'espace qui précède la restitution du
passeport de faire échec par une mesure
de police à l'utilisation de ce
passeport nous a aimés pour autant
considéré illégal par l'autorité qui
utilise l'article 40 est précisément ce
qui manque dans
les diligences accomplies c'est une
demande adressée soit par vous mêmes
soit à la présidence de la république au
ministre de l'intérieur de faire en
sorte que ce passeport soit interceptée
s'il est utilisé à la sortie du
territoire national et ça amène deuxième
question de ma part est ce que monsieur
le ministre puisque le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république
nous a révélé tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait eu depuis le 1er août va utiliser
à sion ou plutôt l'utilisation pour 20
voyages de ce passeport et nous a
renvoyés vers vous en nous annonçant que
vous soyez en mesure de vous apporter
des précisions sur ce point
ce qui nous intéresse c'est de savoir si
ces vins utilisation ont été faites à
partir du territoire national ou
seulement à l'arrivée dans notre pays si
c'est à l'arrivée dans d'autres pays
nous ne pouvons pas reprocher aux
autorités de chad yens 2 d'avoir excepté
lusage par un ressortissant français de
son propre passeport diplomatique mais
si c'est à la sortie du territoire
national
la question est d'une tout autre nature
et donc comment avez vous eu finalement
la formation que 20 voyages avaient eu
lieu
d'où vient cette information est ce que
c'est une information de police
est ce que c'est une information de
services de renseignement est ce que
c'est une information des postes
diplomatiques et qu'est ce qui permet
d'affirmer que dans ces 20 voyages il a
utilisé le passeport est est-ce que
c'est au départ ou à l'arrivée je n'ai
pas compétence en matière de police mais
au niveau de la question de l'arrivée je
peux vous donner les éléments
d'information que vous demandez le
chiffre d'une vingtaine de voyages que
vous évoquez me paraît tout à fait
plausible
que l'ensemble de ses voyages a été
effectué sur les déplacements étaient
effectués par un passeport diplomatique
me paraît aussi par le biais d'un des
deux passeports diplomatiques me paraît
aussi tout à fait plausible parce que
lorsque j'ai eu connaissance des faits
au tchad
j'ai demandé à notre poste de s'informer
auprès des autorités tchadiennes
si elle voulait bien nous faire savoir
si monsieur benalla avait utilisé son
passeport diplomatique lorsqu'il était
arrivé à djamena et les autorités
tchadiennes ont confirmé qu'ils avaient
utilisé le passeport diplomatique
par ailleurs j'ai interrogé un certain
nombre de postes qui me paraissaient
correspondre à des informations que je
pouvais lire ici ou là y compris
d'ailleurs des informations je sais pas
comment il s'appelle de monsieur salomon
qui lui-même se vantait que monsieur ben
alla utiliser son passeport diplomatique
en indiquant d'ailleurs lui même né je
crois que monsieur benalla fait la même
chose ce qui est une imaginaire fertile
qu'à partir du moment où monsieur
benalla je prends l'exemple de hoyo est
une ville de du congo brazzaville où il
est allé voir le président sasso et il a
alors affiché ce slogan qui le dit dans
un journal je ne sais plus lequel je
passe avec un passeport diplomatique et
donc tout le monde sait où je suis or
vous savez bien que le passeport n'est
pas un outil de police ni de
renseignements et le bruit ou la rumeur
ou les propos mêmes gens très sérieux
selon lesquelles quand on a un passeport
diplomatique le ministre affaires
étangères sait où se trouvent tous les
titulaires du passeport diplomatique on
serait alors dans un état
ce serait la fin des fins de droit et
donc ses propos sont dans l'imaginaire
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs dont
monsieur pénale a en tout cas je reviens
mon argumentation
à partir du moment où je constate que là
il fait savoir que
il utilise son passeport diplomatique
j'ai sollicité un certain nombre de
postes pour des lieux où il était censé
s'être rendu et j'ai eu de la part du
tchad mais aussi des autorités
israéliennes
la confirmation que c'est bien le
passeport diplomatique qui a été utilisé
j'en déduis donc l'ensemble des voyages
qui a été effectué en dû l'être avec le
passeport diplomatique il ya une
vingtaine de voyages qui ont été faits
avec des dates qu'on connaît qu'on re
coup parce que lui même ou ses proches
en le se sont beaucoup répandu sur ce
sujet là il ya eu le maroc et le bar
massy avant tout une série de deux pays
du fait divers et variés j'en déduis que
le passeport diplomatique et utilise a
été utilisé dans tous les cas de figure
merci de votre réponse monsieur le
ministre si vous voulez bien nous allons
revenir au renouvellement du premier
passeport diplomatique qui a été délivré
dans des conditions quelque peu
surprenante
tout d'abord la demande avait été
formulée le 23 mai 2018 le lendemain du
retour des quinze jours de suspension de
monsieur bénard et la demande a été
présentée alors même qu'il n'avait plus
vocation à se déplacer à l'étranger
puisque ses supérieurs lui avait retiré
la préparation et l'organisation des
déplacements officiels du président de
la république 1 vous nous avez indiqué
tout à l'heure que vous n'étiez pas vous
en mesure au ministère des affaires
étrangères de connaître cet élément je
ne vous interrogerait pas sur ce point
j'entends ce que ce que mon nom ne
l'indiqué cependant quand même un
élément sur lequel vous pouvez me
répondre je pensais que le deuxième
caractère surprenant de cette demande et
qu'elle n'a pas été présentée par la
voie hiérarchique normal c'est à dire le
service du protocole de la présidence de
la république mais bien par monsieur b
dallas directement qui manifestement n'a
pas référer à ses supérieurs
comment se fait-il que vos services
traite cette demande qui finalement est
formulée par un chargé de mission de
l'elysée sans que le service du
protocole ne soit en charge de cette
demande et alors même que
elle a été faite à l'insu de son service
puisqu'il était possible de supputer
madame il s'agit à ce moment-là du chef
de cabinet adjoint du président de la
république
l'adjoint chef de cabine charge et
singulièrement de la préparation et de
l'organisation des voyages à l'étranger
il est temps en possession d'un
passeport dont il demande le
renouvellement et je ne suis pas informé
à ce moment-là personne d informer dans
mon administration du fait qu' il a été
suspendu d'une part et qu'il n'a plus
ses fonctions d'autre part et donc
classiquement lorsqu'il ya un
renouvellement puisque dans la première
la première attribution vérifie
l'ensemble des données concernant les
demandeurs y compris concernant les
services de l'elysée la validation par
le service du protocole on demande même
à ce moment là le contrat de travail
pour opter pour demander pour attribuer
le passeport à partir du moment où
c'était un renouvellement de liés à la
fonction avec des gens des services avec
lesquels mes propres services
travaillent régulièrement pour
l'organisation des voyages crois que le
service concerné n'y a pas vu ma dignité
et à engager la procédure simplement ce
que vous avez oublié c'est que on
envoyait copie de l'information au
service du protocole
compte tenu de quand même de la qualité
de nos services
oui de la qualité de nos ambassades
oui et du fait que monsieur benalla
quand même acquis une certaine notoriété
et que je suppose on s'intéresse
peut-être dans certains services à son
activité je ne sais pas je fais des
hypothèses
vous paraît-il plausible qu'il soit reçu
par le chef de l'état sans que personne
à l'ambassade de france au tchad ne se
rendent compte dans soient informés ne
vous saisissent de cette question
l'homme c'est une bonne question
monsieur l'association permet de rêver
je suis un habitué du tchad pour des
moutons dire aujourd'hui on pourrait en
parler y est par ailleurs et je sais que
quand on connaît l'aéroport de djamena
on imagine bien que un avion privé de
qualité qui se posent à djamena ne passe
jamais inaperçu voilà je vais aussi par
des sauvegardes aéroports hausse à ce
que ça se remarque
j'ai interrogé le 26 décembre
notre ambassadeur sur ce sujet il m'a
fait savoir qu'il était informé de ce
déplacement et qu'il n'avait pas
considéré qu'il fallait en faire rapport
je lui ai fait savoir que c'était
regrettable il a reconnu c'était une
erreur d'appréciation d'un événement
visuel qui avait été observé par tel ou
tel et il considérait que c'était la
relation entre le président deby est un
individu tandis que l'individu était pas
seul pour la ce que je peux vous dire
j'ai fait les observations nécessaire à
notre ambassade
mais pour terminer vous nous avez dit
que la copie de l'attribution du
passeport diplomatique avait été envoyé
au protocole de l'elysée et il ya peut
être les réactions parce que ce qui est
bizarre voyez vous c'est que monsieur
benalla s'en passer comme dit madame
jourdain sans passer par le service
officiel du protocole de l'elysée
demandent individuellement donc un
passeport diplomatique le renouvellement
du passeport diplomatique même il n'est
plus chargé nommé et donc je conclus et
et vous allez me dire si je comprends
bien monsieur le ministre e au moment où
monsieur benalla et des chargés de
l'organisation des voyages y compris à
l'étranger puisqu'il un passeport
diplomatique le ministre des affaires
étrangères n'en est pas informée mais
retrouver vous trouvez normal à partir
du moment où la personne qui s'occupe
d'organiser les voyages à l'étranger
sont venus décharger connais monsieur
noms ne vous disent pas monsieur le
rapporteur et c'est le moi je n'ai pas à
m'immiscer dans l'organisation interne
de l'elysée mon interlocuteur principal
c'est le chef de cabinet du président de
la république et chargé lui-même
globalement de l'organisation des
déplacements et il se fait des idées
entre pas monsieur v nations à sa nombre
de deux déplacements et donc du coup
lorsqu'il demande le renouvellement d'un
passeport qui avait été tout à fait
légalement attribués personne n'y trouve
à redire ça arrive dans beaucoup de cas
et dans le monde obtenant beaucoup
d'administrations pour ceux qui ont un
passeport diplomatique il est donc
renouvelée et on le fait savoir le
notifie que le notifie faut d'abord si
on pouvait les entendre on va pas buzzé
vous savez c'est réentendre l'elysée
quand même c'est étrange que le service
du protocole recevant votre notification
comme quoi vous lui avait renouvelé son
passeport alors que le service du
protocole je suppose je n'ignore pas
qu'il a été déchargée genève ne savait
pas parce que s'ils service w de golf et
en toute bonne foi si ç'avait du
protocole ni ignore le fait que la
personne a été déchargé de
l'organisation de ses gongs et un manque
de circulation de l'information ou qu'on
a tellement voulu que cette décharge de
ses fonctions fût et restât discrète que
finalement ni le ministre des affaires
étrangères ni ses services ni même le
service du protocole de l'elysée n'en
avaient été informées
bon le passeport diplomatique avez-vous
dit a été invalidée et effectivement
comme on est dans une forme de novation
vous l'avez expliqué vous utiliser ce
terme invalidée mais nous ne savons pas
exactement ce qu'il signifie qu'est ce
que ça veut dire matériellement une fois
qu'il est invalidée qu'est ce qui se
passe s'il est utilisé deuxième
deuxièmement à quelle date vous l'avez
peut-être dit tout à l'heure mais je
voudrais que nous leur disiez à quelle
date cette invalidation at-elle été
effective et quelles consignes ont été
données aux différents services
compétents à la suite de la validation
ce ne sont pas des consignes la question
de la validation
je les ai dit tout à l'heure c'est pas
de faire un autodafé du passeport c'est
de rendre son usage
impossible et j'ai indiqué que la
difficulté était de l'interconnexion
entre les bases de données y compris
pour permettre à la police de l'air et
des frontières de tel ou tel endroit de
faire en sorte que le clou lorsque le
passeport est présente et ça ça fasse le
bruit nécessaire pour que l'on se rende
compte que il n'est plus ici n'est plus
valide c'est ça le sujet et pour
préciser ma question mais parce que
j'avais préparé compris la question lors
d'un septette fois qu'il est mal b
formulée mais vous comprenez je pense
que la police de l'air et des frontières
elle est encadrée par
des fonctionnaires qui ont une marge
d'appréciation et c'est pas simplement
quand l'ordinateur fait sont qu'une
alerte peut être donné je comprends très
bien que quand on introduit dans un
ordinateur un dispositif ça apporte une
assistance aux fonctionnaires de police
qui sont là parce que l'alerté donnée
par un mécanisme automatique mais il
existe certainement aussi des moyens
pour que l'état donne à ses services de
police des instructions dire si monsieur
benalla que vous reconnaîtrez peut-être
sa photo est parue dans le journal
devait utiliser un passeport
diplomatique retirer le lui est ce que
ceci à la suite de vos demandes a été
fait est-ce que l'invalidation du
passeport à cette conséquence dans le
fonctionnement de l'état
il ne peut plus voyager avec un
passeport diplomatique oui bien sûr
désormais non une part parce que cette
invalidation at elle eu lieu à 26 ou 27
28 décembre donc donc il est sur les
fichiers d'interpol et l'effet sur les
fichiers schengen et je les dis dans mon
propos de départ et c'est là c'est sous
l'autorité de l'intérieur ma
responsabilité demander la validation ce
que vous allez faire ce que j'aime fed à
trois reprises à deux reprises ces deux
reprises très très bien je vous remercie
de ses réponses effet à deux reprises
mais c'est là qu'on s'est retrouvé
confronté ouf au précédent du fait qu'il
n'y avait jamais eu n'a pas l'innovation
de les verser à mater dans l'histoire et
donc et donc mais là n'était pas armé
pour faire face à ce genre de défi et
dans les fonctionnalités d d d d outils
informatiques
oui mais il n'y avait pas un valide à
sion donc pour retrouver le détail de
vous faire admettre qu'il n'ya pas que
des ordinateurs pour faire fonctionner
la police n'était pas recherché par la
justice à ma connaissance
et oui mais ils pouvaient faire l'objet
d'instructions pour utilisation illégale
d'un père biais d'un passeport
diplomatique d'instruction individuelle
et donner la parole tout d'abord à
monsieur phrase ça qui la demandent
merci monsieur le président
un monsieur le ministre il se trouve que
comme sénateur des français de
l'étranger
je suis moi-même titulaires d'un
passeport diplomatique
oui comme l'ensemble de mes collègues
sénateurs des français l'étranger et par
un heureux hasard j'ai un visa pour le
tchad
c'est un visa quand on a un passeport
diplomatique on l'obtient en fournissant
une note verbale peut-être première
question que j'ai à vous poser monsieur
le ministre
pourriez vous rappeler aux membres de la
commission denquête qui sont moins
habitués que nous avons voyagé avec un
tel document ce qu'est une autre verbal
comment elle se délivre par qui et pour
quoi faire puisque pour le tchad pour
voyager au tchad
on entre quand on a un passeport
diplomatique avec un visa
la deuxième chose pouvez vous donc me
confirmer qu'il faut une autre verbal
pour obtenir un visa diplomatique sur un
passeport diplomatique
la troisième question monsieur benalla
at il sollicité une ou des notes
verbales auprès du bureau des visas et
passeport diplomatique de votre
ministère pour demander des visas
diplomatiques
sinon comment est il entré avec son
passeport diplomatique au tchad qui
n'est pas un pays avec exemption de visa
comme l'est le congo et dans le cas
contraire et comme l'a déclaré le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république à propos de la façon dont
monsieur benalla aurait obtenu un second
passeport de service pensez vous que
monsieur benalla aurait pu utiliser de
fausse note verbale en vue d'obtenir de
vrais visas diplomatiques seul ministre
partie des questions qui concernent les
autorités tchadiennes ne vais pas
répondre à leur place
moi je n'ai pas été informé d'une note
verbale concernant monsieur pénale à une
solide et sollicitant à auprès de
l'ambassade du tchad à paris un visa
pour son déplacement au tchad
je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir toutes les
informations se je connais pas la
réglementation propre de chacun des pays
mais je ne suis pas sûr que pour un
court séjour il soit obligatoire d'avoir
un visa pour le club je me suis pas
certain mais enfin c'est à vérifier mais
en tout cas votre question sinon bien
non aux trois questions
alors maintenant je donne la parole
merci d'abord à madame lherbier à
monsieur jacques bigot merci le
président je suis ministre
on a compris que monsieur benalla après
son licenciement fin juillet a très
rapidement trouver une activité
apparemment particulière d'intermédiaire
à l'international dans des affaires avec
des relations avec un homme d'affaires
dès lors comme nous l'a rappelé
d'ailleurs ministre l'intérieur monsieur
bénard avait aucune interdiction de
sortie du territoire ils pouvaient
utiliser un passeport ordinaire demander
des visas et circuler l'utilisation de
passeports diplomatiques pourrait
peut-être lui faciliter l'entrée mais ce
que josé under qui peut-être pas de
mention de la profession sur le
passeport diplomatique est ce que le
fait d'avoir un passeport diplomatique
et de faire usage comme il l'a fait
d'ailleurs pour vous demander le
renouvellement de 23-20 du stage
pratique d'une fonction qui n'avait plus
a pu lui faciliter les relations qu'il a
nourri à l'international et dans ce cas
là et ça rejoint notre notre mission est
ce qu'on ne risquait pas de mettre notre
président de la république en danger par
le fait que l'en de ses anciens
collaborateurs pouvait continuer à faire
croire qu'il était encore collaborateur
qui l'avait donc des droits d'entrée
particulière et des relations
particulières sur les intermédiaires
monsieur bigot et je crois qu'il ya une
autre question aussi sur les
intermédiaires mois
je suis très très très clair et très
ferme là dessus je ne connais pas
d'intermédiaire et je souhaite ne pas en
connaître et j'ai fait savoir à la
demande du président de la république à
l'ensemble de nos postes que personne ne
pouvait se prétendre intermedia de
quiconque
madame mercier merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre c'est une
affaire très confuse ça on a du mal à y
voir clair j'ai une question très simple
monsieur bénard avait de nombreuses
missions je parle avant le 1er mai 2018
il était chargé d'organiser les voyages
à l'étranger de monsieur le président de
la république
connaissiez vous monsieur benalla je ne
vous demande pas ce que vous en pensiez
connaissiez vous monsieur benalla
deuxièmement vous nous avez indiqué que
pour obtenir un passeport diplomatique
il fallait un contrat de travail donc
son passeport diplomatique qu'il avait
demandé le 23 mai et qu'il a eue le 24
mai 2008
pouvez vous nous dire pour quelle durée
il avait eu ce passeport sur connaissez
vous monsieur benalla non je ne crois
que je crois que j'ai jamais vu mais
peut-être qu'il m'a vu lui mais moi je
ne connais pas le contrat travail était
de 5 ans et est donc là lusage veut
savait que nous ne pouvons pas accorder
de passeport diplomatique que pour une
durée de 10 ans et entre un an et dix
ans est à la discrétion du ministre en
charge et généralement on affecte les
durées tout ça est un petit peu à mon
avis un peu artisanal entre un deux
trois ou cinq ans en fonction du contrat
du mandat de l'activité de la personne
et c'est renouvelable
voilà ce que je peux répondre mais ces
messieurs criant compléter ce look si
c'était de cinq ans 18 et 5 ça fait 23
morts qui étaient jusqu'à 2022 par danse
étaient 4 jusqu'à la fin c'était jusqu'à
la fin de son de son mandat de sa
mission de sa mission qui s'est terminée
le g10 en commençant jeunes et même la
date de péremption
c'était valable
le deuxième passeport jusqu'en jusqu'en
juin jusqu'en jusqu'au jusqu'au 19
septembre 2022
quelle date et précises ou en tous les
cas à l'expiration de la fonction de
monsieur bénard à aller ou à
l'expiration de la fonction de super nes
évidemment c'est lié à la fonction bien
sûr cependant c'est autrement il tombe
est valable dans tout le monde
voilà pour les temps forts des travaux
de la commission d' enquête sénatoriale
sur la sphère benalla pour rappel
alexandre benalla a été convoqué lui
même par les sénateurs une audition à
suivre lundi 21 janvier dès 13h30 sur
notre antenne très bonne soirée à tous
sur public sénat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]